[Music]
in terms of psychiatry many people are
scared of psychiatry and they've told me
that the images of a clockwork orange
come to mind that psychiatrists have
exposed people to these horrible
thoughts or horrible ideas and pictures
and do terrible things that's not what
happens in a psychiatry office or what
happens in a hospital when a
psychiatrist comes to visit a patient
hey gq i'm dr eric bender and this is
part two of the breakdown
[Music]
the dark knight
why do you want to kill me
i don't want to kill you
what would i do without you go back to
ripping off mob dealers no no
no
no you
you complete
me the joker is clearly a psychopath
innately he just has no love for anybody
just himself the joker is clearly doing
this to get personal gratification he
even jokingly says to batman but he's
serious you complete me this is about
the joker this is not about anybody but
the joker clearly psychopathic he's not
psychotic there's a big difference
between being psychotic and psychopathic
being psychotic means that someone has
had a break from reality they might be
hearing voices
seeing things that other people don't
see they might believe things other
people don't believe and there's
evidence to show it's not true but they
still believe it that's called a
delusion they might be
having very jumbled thinking that's what
psychotic means or what a psychosis is
psychopathy is very different
psychopathy is this tendency to just use
people in their game and joker even uses
the word game this is a game to him i'm
considering it no there's only minutes
left you're gonna have to play my little
game if you want to save one of them
yeah
here the joker this is right after these
crimes have been committed there is no
evidence that he is hearing things
seeing things having a break from
reality he clearly knows what he's doing
he tells batman the specific addresses
where rachel and harvey dent are he's at
250 522nd street and she's uh on avenue
he knows it he's even said you've let
five people die ten people have taken
over for you he's clearly a sound mind
here when you're looking at legal sanity
you first need a mental illness to say
was there a mental illness that caused
this person not to know what he was
doing at the time of the crime so we
don't have a mental illness but let's
just say that somehow he gets to court
and he is going to be evaluated and
somebody argues well clearly he's he's
got something going on true but again
that's psychopathy and psychopathy is
not a mental illness that would qualify
for what's called the insanity defense
in the insanity defense that means that
because of a mental illness someone
didn't know that what they were doing at
the time of a crime was right or wrong
in gotham city let's assume it's that
someone doesn't know the difference
between right and wrong if he were found
to have a mental illness that caused him
to not know that he could go to a
psychiatric hospital a forensic hospital
where he would then be treated but again
he doesn't have anything that needs to
be treated
where are they
killing is making a cholesterol
where are they it feels between one
[Music]
here we just see the joker really loving
torturing batman and hurting other
people that's something that a
psychopath really would revel in
don't talk like one of them you're not
even if you'd like to be
to them you're just a freak like me
there's an article that came out almost
20 years ago by william martens who was
a physician in the united kingdom and it
was somewhat controversial called the
hidden suffering of the psychopath dr
martins had interviewed serial killers
including jeffrey dahmer and dennis
nielsen
and he claimed that both of those
individuals didn't know how to interact
with the world they felt
excluded and as if they couldn't figure
things out that no one loved them they
also came from traumatic backgrounds and
jeffrey dahmer said to him per dr
martin's report that there was a point
at which he crossed any thin connection
he would have to
the societal norms and at that point he
felt so isolated and that's when his
crimes escalated
jeffrey dahmer even tried to keep his
victims alive he tried to zombify them
by injecting acid into their brains
dennis nilsson kept body parts and would
even talk to the bodies for hours at a
time write poetry to them even this
shows that psychopaths might in fact not
understand how to interact with the
world that article was very
controversial because people think
psychopathy and psychopaths have
committed such heinous crimes should we
really have some sympathy for them the
idea was to think how does psychopathy
develop are those traits that we should
look out for in people to suggest that
they might go down a path towards
psychopathy it's not necessarily to say
hey we need to be sympathetic but that's
something to keep in mind what does make
someone go down this path
of not caring about people
see i'm not a monster
i'm just ahead of the curve
joker saying that he's not a monster he
recognizes what he is that's very much
the way dahmer and nielsen explain to dr
martens they recognize what they were
they said we couldn't show the side to
anybody they'd be so repulsed nobody
would connect with them they already
weren't connecting with the world so we
do think that psychopaths might
recognize who they are how they function
in the world and not know how to do it
the godfather
[Music]
but if clemenza can figure a way
to have a weapon planted there for me
then i'll kill them both
michael corleone
ends up taking on this role of killing
salazo and mccloskey
he seems to come into this because it
involves family it's the family business
in some ways the idea that it's a family
business justifies this it almost makes
it so it's just a business decision he
can balance out whatever feelings he
might have about killing someone with
the fact that he's gonna kill them so
that's
managing his cognitive dissonance that
that conflict between those two ideas at
the same time what's important to know
here is that this is almost an
acceptable code of conduct in the mafia
as presented in this movie you got to
get up close like this but a bing you
blow their brains all over your nice
cyber league suit
come here
you're taking us very personally what's
presented in the film is that this would
be expected this is a retribution
there's an idea that this is acceptable
to some degree now while michael has to
go off and hide in italy for years
because of this
it's not unexpected it's part of the
system in that way at this point in the
film he's not necessarily a psychopath
he's doing something that he sees
there's a reason to do it it's part of
the family business this involves a
family the fact that someone tried to
kill his father it's not a
pleasurable event it's not something
that he's getting joy out of in the way
that say someone who's a serial killer
or even a psychopath might get a power
and control
excitement from he's doing this as
retribution and in that way it's not
necessarily marking him as a psychopath
it's not legal
so that might qualify him more in an
anti-social personality disordered realm
but he's not necessarily showing a lack
of empathy to all people it's this
situation that's a business situation
that he needs to handle tom wait a
minute i'm talking about a cop that's
mixed up in drugs i'm talking about a a
dishonest cop
a crooked cop who got mixed up in the
rackets and got what was coming
the anti-social personality traits here
would be disregard for the law
potentially lying and manipulating which
we know that he does
there is the question of is he a
psychopath and if we look at all of the
different
iterations
he would probably be more of that old
idea of a sociopath that the environment
in which he's in now as a young adult
has created this uncaring person he
still cares about family
so there's that
that's going for him in the opposite
direction but the idea that society and
what he's involved in has made him this
way
that's different than psychopathy
and it's really
a good debate as to whether he would be
or wouldn't be a psychopath there are
things that argue for it such as his
violent behavior or
ordering people to be killed and not
caring about it just seeing it as
business whereas there's evidence that
he might not be that he really does care
about children and other members of his
family on that side however we have seen
that psychopaths from the research can
feel
some care and some concern for their
family members this one is really a
tricky one to parse out
clockwork orange
i'm going to show you some slides and
you're going to tell me what you think
about them all right oh jolly good the
exercise that alex undergoes here is
very similar to a study that was
recently done with psychopaths in that
study a neutral face was shown and it
was changed into something a little bit
more emotional people who scored high on
the psychopathy checklist showing traits
of psychopathy actually had a harder
time even figuring out or understanding
what the emotion was that the person was
showing it suggests that they have a
really hard time understanding or
processing other people's emotions
here we see alex give some
responses
in this movie what they're trying to
show is that he's been conditioned to be
less ultra violent those were the terms
in the movie
he had been conditioned meaning
he had associated something violent
images that's the scene where his eyes
are held open and he's looking at
violent images and beethoven's music
which he loves they've been paired
together to condition him so that each
time he hears that music he wants to not
go near it or that each time he is
exposed to something that reminds me of
violent images he won't want to go near
them that was the idea of exposing him
to those things
the boy you always quarreled with is
seriously ill
my mind is a blank
uh
and i'll smash your face for you your
blockos
what studies have shown that the brains
of psychopaths reveal is there's less
activity in areas that process emotion
or that are involved in decision making
or even that link emotions and decisions
and actions so the orbital frontal
cortex the frontal part of your brain
right above your eye socket
has less activity in a psychopath and
that part of the brain has to do with
decision making and actions towards
others
and the striatum which is another part
deeper in the brain that has to do with
emotional processing as well as the
amygdala also in the back of the brain
and another part the anterior insula
another part of your brain between the
frontal and parietal lobes those are all
involved in processing of emotion and
they all show less activity based on
images and studies of psychopaths so
when he's talking about doctors being
inside of his gulliver inside of his
mind
there have been studies to look inside
people's minds it's interesting that
this movie came out decades ago but we
are still doing some types of studies
like these today
what do you want
uh no time for the old in and out love
i've just come to read the meter good
i think what she's trying to do here is
she's trying to show a good bedside
manner she's trying to make him
comfortable she's trying to make it so
that he'll be willing to answer her
questions she's not threatening him in
any way she's presenting with these
things i think this is also part of an
assessment has this conditioning worked
when alex looks at these pictures is he
thinking about ultra violent things he
mentions sex the in and out he mentions
breaking eggs
shoving a watch up somebody's behind but
it's not clear that he's ultra violent
so i think her involvement is furthering
an assessment of how this experiment on
him has worked
one thing about a clockwork orange
that's important to mention is
in terms of psychiatry many people
are scared of psychiatry and they've
told me that the images of a clockwork
orange come to mind that psychiatrists
have exposed people to these horrible
thoughts or horrible ideas and pictures
and do terrible things that's not what
happens in a psychiatry office or what
happens in a hospital when a
psychiatrist comes to visit the patient
wall street
fool and his money are lucky enough to
get together in the first place but why
do you need to wreck this company
because it's wreckable all right
i took another look at it i changed my
mind gordon gekko really shows traits of
narcissism here he's preoccupied with
this fantasy of money and power and
accumulating more and more and more in
addition to that narcissistic trait he
also shows the trait of lack of empathy
he is totally disregarding the father in
the company here he's disregarding what
he said to people he's lying he's
manipulating people
and that's all he cares about this is
what some people have termed
white-collar psychopathy or someone
who's not necessarily doing violent
crimes
but
involved in the financial world or other
places there's a book that came out
years ago called snakes in suits which
talks about how some people in positions
of power show traits of psychopathy
so tell me gordon
when does it all end huh how many yachts
can you water ski behind how much is
enough it's not a question of enough pal
it's a zero-sum game somebody wins
somebody loses
we could look at why does psychopathy
even exist one idea is that it's the
survival of the fittest those that can
take advantage of a situation will those
that can in fact survive want to survive
as best as they can there's another idea
that psychopathy exists because it
teaches us how to defend against those
things and even very pure genetic
cultures where there are very few people
that come into that genetic pool
there are psychopaths still that arise
the idea is that perhaps this happens
because we need to learn how to defend
against it or again is there something
evolutionarily
that a psychopath has that is worth
preserving some people who rise to
positions of power
use what they can to get ahead and that
can be a version of psychopathy money
itself isn't lost or made it's simply uh
transferred from one perception to
another
like magic greed is good gordon gekko
he's the one who who came up with that
that is the idea that
hey what i accumulate that's what
matters most i don't care about other
people
anybody underneath me these are just
pawns in my game i'm going to accumulate
as much wealth as i can greed is good
caring isn't it doesn't serve me and
that's what we see in him
no country for old men
what's the most you ever lost on a coin
toss
sir the most you ever lost i'm not going
to us
i don't know so at this point your hairs
are starting to stand on end a little
bit and it feels like you just want to
get away from this person that's a
feeling
many people describe when they're around
someone who's psychopathic the idea that
this guy is literally just toying with a
man behind the counter and he's getting
a lot of personal gratification out of
it you see that it's about power it's
about making sure that he can show this
person that he's in control anton shugar
is just trying to get this guy scared
call it
calling yes
for what just got it
well we need to know what we're calling
it for here you need to call it
a psychopath is often glib meaning they
will express themselves but very
shallowly you don't know what's really
going on underneath you see some of that
here in the back and forth the banter
but it's more than banter it's really an
attempt to
make this guy distressed and have him
feel a lot of fear what sugar does here
he essentially makes his decision about
killing this guy come down to a coin
toss there's one theory that this might
be related to something serial killers
do by dehumanizing their victims the
idea is that the coin toss or
dehumanizing a victim and not seeing
them as a person helps someone deal with
what's called cognitive dissonance or
the idea that this is wrong and the
feeling they might have that this is not
okay or the feeling that others might
have it this is not okay but by making
it all just come down to a coin toss or
objectifying somebody then then it's all
right it's justified
so that could be what you see here that
might suggest that someone has more
caring and awareness than a psychopath
might have
but they might know again if it relates
to them and their goals that a family
member of theirs might be upset by their
crimes so in that sense maybe they're
aware of this and thinking
maybe i shouldn't be doing this but
again they don't feel it the
dehumanizing helps somebody get through
something if there is that cognitive
dissonance
it's also a way to continue to
make someone very distressed this guy's
life has just been
minimized into a coin toss or someone
who's going to be killed by a serial
killer has just been treated as an
object
that's also a power and control thing or
could be a power and control dynamic
established by the serial killer or by
the psychopath
i can't call it for you
well you wouldn't be fair
i didn't put nothing out yes you did
you've been putting it up your whole
life you just didn't know it
there was a criticism of this film when
it came out that the character of sugar
was not developed fully but the fact is
that with psychopaths you don't actually
know what's under the surface you don't
get to know them in a deep way this has
to do with that glibness of their
expression pathological lying just not
knowing
heads in
well done
the fact that this gentleman might have
gotten the coin toss right and for his
lucky sake he did
means that there is a way he could still
live sugar was not determined to kill
him in a way again that's sugar
toying with this guy he's playing with
him he's literally using him as a pawn
in his game for personal gratification
and that is an element of psychopathy in
some of the most severe cases of
narcissistic personality disorder also
you can see that lack of empathy for
other people
so that's probably what's going on here
it's an element of psychopathy an
element of narcissism in sugar
basic instinct
boxing was fun till manny died
how'd you feel when he died
i loved him it hurt how'd you feel when
i told you johnny boza died
i felt like someone read my book and was
playing a game
catherine is showing signs of
histrionic personality disorder someone
with histrionic personality disorder
wants to be the center of attention and
they're uncomfortable when they're not
they might use sexual or provocative
behavior to become the center of
attention they might use their physical
appearance as well to gain someone's
attention or affection you still get the
pleasure
didn't you ever [ __ ] anybody else when
you were married nick
how'd you know he was married
maybe i was just guessing
in addition someone who's histrionic
they might have shallow shifting
expression of emotions or even their
speech might be dramatic or in some ways
impressionistic trying to leave someone
with a little bit of flair
when it comes to catherine in terms of
showing sexual behavior provocative
behavior here she is
flirting with nick out in the open
there's the famous crossing of the legs
where she exposes herself that's again
using sexuality to gain attention you
want me to take a lie detector test
what's interesting at the end of this
there is the beating of the lie detector
in some studies psychopaths actually
have less skin conductivity meaning that
there's less of the electrical
conduction that goes along the skin
that's important when using a lie
detector in fact because the reliability
of a lie detector is not completely
accurate
it can't be admissible in court so
it's not out of the question that she
would pass a lie detector what's also
possible although it's not clear is
whether catherine's a sexual sadist
sexual sadism refers to someone who
derives pleasure from the extreme pain
suffering or humiliation of someone else
in her case she is talking about liking
what manny did for her and there's
allusions to violent or rough sex and
sexual activity in addition we know that
she has
some tendency towards the more violent
when it comes to sex catherine
potentially is a sexual sadist there are
different degrees and types of sexual
sadists there are characteristics
sometimes people torture their victims
sexually for longer than an hour
sometimes people have more than one way
to torture their victims
how did you meet mr bias i wanted to
write a book about the murder of a
retired rock and roll star i went down
to his club i picked him up and i had
sex with him
[Music]
you didn't feel anything for him you
just had sex with him for your book in
the beginning
research on psychopathy shows that there
is this mix of personality disorder
traits that can be narcissistic they can
be borderline they can be histrionic
the classic psychopath is someone who
does not care
does whatever he or she wants doesn't
think about how it affects others uses
others manipulates others can be glib
can really do whatever they need to to
get into a situation to get out of it
what they want so in that sense
catherine really does show signs of
being a psychopath
ozarks
i can't do this
i can't i can't marty i can't do this
are you driving i can't do this pull
over right now honey shouldn't be
driving
wendy you're our whole life honey
sometimes people make decisions do
things that are illegal
and make bad decisions even when they're
not psychopathic or they don't have
antisocial personality disorder or some
personality disorder in this case wendy
had to make this decision
in her mind because if she didn't
give up her brother
she would risk her own life her
husband's life and the lives of her
children she chose here to give up her
brother so that she could protect her
family the decisions she makes to have
him killed
she clearly does care about him she's
crying she's hysterical about having to
make this decision if she were a true
psychopath this would not be happening
she has no one here to act for so she's
not acting this way in front of anybody
she actively calls her husband to share
her grief so in this case this is not an
example of a psychopath i can't do it i
can't do this i can't why do i stop him
do i stop him
maybe just breathe what are we doing
what am i doing
some might argue that wendy
arranged for the killing of kate
langmore that she's also
doing other bad things and and she's
developing a coldness to her and that's
quite possible she might be doing that
to survive which is different than a
psychopathic motivation she's not doing
this for her pleasure she's got to
survive she and marty are in this
there's no way out so this is the only
way she does this is to figure out who
do i need to kill who do i need to
keep alive what do i need to do to
survive that is different than
psychopathic behavior even though she's
become more cold more callous in showing
those psychopathic traits
thanks so much for watching these clips
with me i hope you learned something and
i look forward to seeing you again